[Música]
hola bienvenidos una vez más a esta
emisión de canadá en las américas café
el espacio que les ofrece cada semana el
servicio en español del radio canadá
internacional se trata en esta ocasión
de la edición correspondiente al 28 de
junio de 2019 con las imágenes
habituales ya nuestra apertura para que
ustedes vayan conociendo distintos
paisajes que les ofrece este país el
segundo en extensión en territorio en el
mundo y hoy estamos aquí presentes en el
estudio de honor a chapman hola
leonardo gimeno que tal buenas tardes
buenas noches
pablo gómez barrios saludos a todas y
todos mi nombre es luis laborda y
estamos con personas invitadas aquí en
nuestro estudio que son maría cordero
pérez hola a todo el mundo del organismo
sendas de ecuador y massiel moreno de la
casa de los colores de nicaragua hola
hola a todas ya todos cuando estos
invitados vamos a estar hablando en unos
instantes más pero antes de eso
queríamos decirles que aquí en canadá
este fin de semana ya estamos entre los
preparativos en todo el país para
celebrar lo que es el día de canadá del
día nacional la fiesta nacional
canadiense que se celebra el próximo
lunes primero de julio y que como cada
año da lugar a una cantidad
innumerable de eventos de todo tipo y
sobre todo de espectáculos tanto en las
grandes como en las pequeñas ciudades de
costa a costa canadiense y en esa
ocasión se celebra la fecha del primero
de julio de 1867 y cuando canadá de
alguna manera se emancipó si lo queremos
decir de esa forma de el reino unido hay
eventos en todos lados los más
tradicionales son por supuesto en las
grandes ciudades como montreal como
toronto y como la capital nacional
ottawa donde hay shows
artísticos de todo tipo y una
tradicional ceremonia de fuegos
artificiales que se lleva a cabo en la
colina del parlamento y quiere decir
también que el primer poquito antes del
primero de julio ya es estamos en
vacaciones escolares se nota vacaciones
de la construcción en la primera semana
de julio se empezaron y ya empezaron y
entonces es un poco el punto de partida
de festejos festivales en todo el país
entre ellos el festival de jazz de
montreal que acaba de empezar y otros
festivales en vancouver en las grandes
ciudades y también en zonas más pequeñas
sin el festival es música cristiana
realmente a otro y lo que abunda son los
espectáculos callejeros por todos lados
festival de jazz que comenzó ayer
[Música]
a esta el festival de los mongoles
eso se ve no está bueno pues se basa una
sendos lugares primeros en ottawa y
después de él y sí creo que también hay
enemy de otros oficios y es increíble es
realmente increíble está en él un
poquito más adelante cerca del mes de
agosto está el festival internacional de
percusión eso para que los los que nos
gusta el folclor ese tipo de cosas que
bueno se basan tanto la percusión este
es el la capital de los festivales casi
el cierre temporal de áfrica que se está
llevando a cabo en este momento que
vienen artistas muchísimos de
comunidades afros de canadá y de todo el
mundo de américa latina también hay
muchísimos y bueno dijo decía el final
de temporada el verano está finalizando
así que empezando
no por qué pero estuvimos en su oficio
aquí es el solsticio el solsticio el
solsticio que significa que se empiezan
a cortar los días
como decía juego de tronos winter scan
en un poco pero yo quería agregar que
para nuestras invitadas acá que dicen
nos acaban de confesar que no regresarán
en invierno aquí a canadá sólo en verano
pues en invierno también hay festivales
en este país entonces pues yo creo que
no aparecen muy convencido
vestidos bien abrigados y sobre todo
bueno como les decimos semana a semana
además de las distintas vías de acceso a
las que ustedes pueden acceder
precisamente para para participar de
esta emisión que son como ustedes ya
conocen nuestro canal de youtube
facebook live y nuestro sitio en
internet www rc y net punto sea ésta
también nuestra aplicación móvil
y va logrando poco a poco más y más
adherentes pero parecería ser que en el
caso del público de el programa en
español la cantidad de bajada esa
aplicación que se han hecho hasta ahora
son menos menores en menor cantidad en
todo caso que han hecho en otras lenguas
exacto no no tengo idea yo supongo que
la gente debe tener la gente que navega
nuestro porque aparte está comprobado
también porque esto todo se mide que más
de 50 por ciento la gente que accede
nuestro sitio
lo accede a partir de un teléfono
celular o de una tableta eso implica que
hay mucha gente que consulta nuestro
sitio
pero william m exacto evidentemente no
les ha dado por bajar la aplicación que
en realidad ese programa mente no ven
ninguna diferencia
es probable es probable la diferencia es
que bueno tiene uno tiene la oferta es
la misma en tanto contenido lo que pasa
es que es mucho más fácil de navegar
es súper fácil por ejemplo escribiendo
un artículo de louis que me interesó por
el de la foto de la araña
es que me apasiono bueno entonces no lo
puedo leer ahora lo puedo guardar y en
la aplicación puedo ir a verlo después
si no tiene aplicación entonces pues si
no guardarlo para después si no con ser
tengo que guardar toda la página en este
caso yo les voy a mostrar cómo hacer
para bajar nuestra aplicación se van
hasta nuestro sitio de internet hacerlo
vio las cookies ahí está la foto que les
decía de la araña de la hermosa la araña
y después bajamos hasta en la casa en el
caso que estén en el móvil y ahí tienen
la publicidad dice aplicación móvil rs y
ustedes hacen clic adentro de esa de ese
banner que es el cartelito y ahí tienen
disponible en apple store y en google
play a pulsar para que los que tengan
producto apple y los que tengan android
salvo huawei dentro de poco tiempo
pueden bajar desde google play en este
caso yo voy a bajar voy a hacer clic en
apple store y me manda directamente a la
aplicación de radio canadá hay figura
como detrás de la venta nacional hay
figura como que yo ya la baje
y que en realidad la borre para
mostrarles a ustedes cómo se llegan a
ser trabajar entonces lo que hacemos es
hacer clic en la pequeña nube si está
que no avalará el proceso para arriba y
ahí está bajando la aplicación se baja
en algunos segundos yo estoy conectar
una red interna así que probablemente
tarde un poquito más de tiempo y
mientras baja poder reiteramos entonces
nosotros que en esa aplicación está
presente todo el contenido decir pueden
seguir los artículos que escribimos los
reportajes que hacemos las entrevistas
que producimos la emisión misma en todos
los materiales especiales etcétera está
todo entre algunos kvist si no me
equivoco que la gente puede ir a parar a
when we wish cuestionarios y horarios
también para esta lista juicios y los
juicios se dice como el juicio al
escabeche y después uno por open o
directamente vamos a logrando el abajo y
ahí aparece nuestra red de acá mesa a lo
civil y por supuesto que le damos la
entrada y ahí están nuestros contenidos
estos son los últimos contenidos
y como decía es súper fácil de manejar y
de instalar en este caso no se ve en la
parte de arriba porque está recortado de
esa manera en la pantalla pero en la
parte de arriba tiene de los audios
si yo lo bajó un poquito ustedes ahí ven
el menú está bien y si cuando ponen
nuestros programas en vídeo por ejemplo
a hacer ahí y nosotros estamos live en
el programa que está en en este momento
estamos también en la aplicación no lo
voy a poner así conocer y está
descargando el buffer para poder ver de
programas sin cortes o sea que es
bastante más fácil ahí lo tienen ahí
bueno justo cuando uno pone el programa
se desactiva
la manera de espejo para que lo vean en
la cámara pero básicamente de eso se
trata pueden bajar la aplicación y les
recomendamos que lo hagan es muy muy
fácil de hacer tanto bajarlas como de
operar la impresión que la lectura es
más fácil uno tiene por ejemplo para la
gente como es lo que tiene presbicia
uno puede agrandar las fuentes ahí abajo
tienen a menos a más a más de la tabla
grande a la led sin salirse de los
espacios exactos yo no tengo que sacarme
los lentes para leer como hago
normalmente por nada de eso pongamos que
yo abro la aplicación y escucho el
programa en la aplicación de mi teléfono
celular los comentarios que se hagan ahí
en ese momento en vivo los podemos ver
acá no porque está dentro del contexto
de youtube o sea los comentarios en
youtube nosotros en este momento lo que
leemos de facebook o que está bien por
qué
estamos conectados con necesidad tenemos
gente que sabemos que nos escribe en
youtube la interacción es mínima por eso
privilegiamos facebook para ver los
comentarios
bueno a propósito de los comentarios ya
hay comentarios danielle camporini nos
dice saludos desde argentina un saludo
daniel y vamos a volver a instantes más
stephanie job él dice tiene un e-mail
para contactarlos y ahí le escribí amlat
de américa latina- amlat
racing rcn punto o sea después karim
google son los está viendo también y
gustavo lucas uno de nuestros software
nos enseña dice la ciudad de melo en
uruguay feliz día de canadá
espero acompañar los festejos tanto en
r6 como en tv5 monde porque todos los
pasan en la parte de la programación que
esta diferencia haciéndose en francia
también pasa en contenidos canadienses
perfecto hecho entonces la invitación
para que bajen la aplicación móvil y nos
puedan seguir a través de sus tabletas
teléfonos móviles etcétera sabemos que
quedan extasiados por este espacio que
les brindamos todos los viernes hasta
ahora pero también pueden volver a
vernos en nuestros equipos móviles
porque no tienen mucho material que
pueden consultar no solamente a través
del sitio de internet
en este programa creo y está comprobado
los tiene olvidados pueden acceder a ese
otro canal es más relativo nos queremos
mucho queremos mucho festival hablando
en serio vamos a ir a nuestros invitados
en el día de hoy los presentamos
rápidamente en el inicio de la emisión
lo reiteramos entonces estamos en
compañía de maría cordero pérez que este
el organismo sendas de ecuador y más y
el moreno de la casa de los colores de
nicaragua nuestros dos invitados tienen
un ya un extensa trayectoria en la
defensa de los derechos de las personas
y particularmente en el caso que nos
ocupa hoy en lo que hace a la defensa de
los derechos de la comunidad el eje de
cv y de sus respectivos países y la
primera pregunta es entonces a
cualquiera de las dos a la que quiera
comenzar a hablar cuál es la situación
de este sector de la sociedad
en sus respectivos países
bueno muchísimas gracias a lc y por la
invitación es un gusto acompañarles y
que la gente de todo el mundo nos esté
escuchando para ecuador es un gusto
poder contarles que hace dos semanas se
aprobó después de seis años de lucha de
trabajo de advocacy a el matrimonio
igualitario esto lo aprobó la corte
constitucional del ecuador y luego de
una larga proceso legal ustedes saben
que tuvo que demandar el registro civil
se tuvo que demandar a la corte local a
la provincial y luego de muchas de
evasiones la corte constitucional por
fin la aprobó y ahora tenemos que
esperar a ver qué resultado tenemos a
nivel de la asamblea porque tiene que
cambiar la legislación en materia civil
nuestro código civil y la constitución
es muy específico gracias a un ex
presidente que tuvimos que hizo que en
la constitución diga que el matrimonio
consiste en un convenio entre hombre y
mujer
ahora esa figura tiene que cambiar y
decidir entre dos personas si aquí dicen
que soy ahora la pareja consiste en el
amor de dos personas punto perfecto y
eso que el amor está hasta medio utópico
pero que era muy lindo piensan bien al
principio si arrancan
si realmente ha sido un ejercicio muy
fuerte muy duro
todavía nos queda cuesta arriba en
ecuador nosotros hemos hecho varias
investigaciones respecto al estado de
situación de los derechos humanos de la
población lgtbi y tenemos datos
terribles porque no formal estamos muy
bien en materia de legislación en
materia política tenemos avances muy
significativos
pero en lo que sustancial es decir en la
cotidianidad en el trato común en la
gente la discriminación y el odio siguen
siendo una constante 7 de cada 10
personas lgtb y en el ecuador han
sufrido algún tipo de violencia o
discriminación en el espacio público 8
de cada 10 en el ambiente familiar en el
ecuador aún existen clínicas de
deshomosexualización o este tratamiento
de conversión que lo llaman en otros
lados como en algunos lugares de eeuu
como en algunos lugares de eeuu casi
siempre liderados por falsos 12 o dos
líderes religiosos o pseudo psicólogos
que están seguros de que ser de la
diversidad sexual es una patología y que
ellos lo pueden curar a curar o revertir
y realmente el cambiar estas
percepciones sobre la diversidad sexual
el cambiar
el conocimiento porque también tenemos
que admitir que en latinoamérica no
tenemos educación sexual integral todo
lo que es educación sexual está
manipulado o manejado desde
si estas cúpulas religiosas entonces la
gente
habla a la gente se expresa o la gente
construye sus imaginarios en base a la
ignorancia en la que están viviendo
entonces realmente el ejercicio es
cuesta arriba o sea tenemos mucho mucho
trabajo por hacer en el tema y
lamentablemente no tenemos un total
respaldo político no sé a nivel de
autoridades hay un buen discurso
políticamente correcto se habla bonito
pero en la práctica no se concreta
absolutamente nada como digo seis años
de pelea por el matrimonio igualitario
hay como avances y retrocesos también yo
creo que me parece que lo que está
diciendo que la corte suprema aprobó por
ley es un paso ya grandísima muy
importante argentina aprobó el
matrimonio igualitario hace algunos años
no hace mucho sin embargo hoy hay una
mujer condenada por un año de cárcel por
haber besado a su compañera en la calle
entonces hay por eso digo a nivel
institucional es una cosa a nivel social
y yo creo que lo que nos toca muchísimo
a los activistas en derechos humanos es
justamente educar para cambiar ese
juicio no hay otra porque el estado no
asume ese error y le pregunto para
afirmar en la misma bueno situación en
nicaragua nada de lo que dijo chavela
hasta el 2008 era ilegal
ser homosexual legal ilegal algo si
entonces luego cambian las leyes y se
legaliza la homosexualidad hay que ver
que en nicaragua hay mucho
desconocimiento sobre lo que significa
ser gay lo que significa ser lesbiana lo
que significa ser trans no tenemos
ningún tipo de estadística como decía
chavela sobre las violencias que viven
las personas no tenemos ninguna ley que
proteja la vida de las personas
diversamente sexuales entonces creo que
nuestra lucha es todavía mucho más larga
que la que chavela tiene ni siquiera hay
un movimiento de la diversidad sexual un
movimiento del sbt establecido que de la
cara durante todo el año se forma uno
durante este mes porque es la marcha del
orgullo y hay que vivir visibilizar y
hay que hacer un montón de cosas pero
luego desaparece es que fue siendo lo
que soy en nicaragua
es que siempre fue así o tal vez no sé
estoy pensando por ejemplo en los años
80 en nicaragua es que la revolución
nicaragüense sandinista produjo algunos
cambios a nivel social es que hubo esto
siempre fue así bueno hasta donde se
después de la revolución lo que hubo fue
mucha persecución de las mujeres
lesbianas de hecho hay un libro que
escribió mary walk que se llama
distintamente completamente diferente o
algo similar porque se me fue el nombre
donde habla como el gobierno
revolucionario sandinista persiguió por
mucho tiempo a las mujeres ya los
cuerpos feminizados así que creo que
siempre ha habido como siempre existió y
escribe esta que la izquierda no ha
significado ninguna relación ni ninguna
alianza con la población lgp y en
latinoamérica
tenemos que ver que todas las
revoluciones centroamericanas o en cuba
o todo el movimiento de izquierda no
incluyó la opción claro hoy o ahora la
nueva corriente del socialismo del siglo
21 tampoco ha aportado nada ni para la
diversidad sexo genérica ni para las
mujeres y en el caso específico de
nicaragua que impide que haya grupos
que represente en estos sectores como
ocurre en todo el resto de américa
latina que está en construcción pero
tiene mucho que ver la cuestión de
educación nosotros tampoco tenemos en la
educación sexual y reproductiva en las
currículas escolares porque hay que
reconocer que nicaragua es un país
católico que tenemos una constitución
que dice que somos un país laico pero
que hace poco se cambia y dice que somos
un país socialista cristiano y solidario
entonces hay una cuestión del choque
fuerte ahí entonces tiene mucho que ver
con la cuestión de protagonismo tiene
mucho mucho que ver con la cuestión de
la educación tiene mucho que ver con que
realmente no tenemos modelos
centroamericanos donde podamos tomar
ejemplos y todo lo demás hoy a nicaragua
ahora tengo entendido que hay como un
retroceso en el tema de la
despenalización del aborto lo que pasó
fue que nos dieron este caramelo de
despenalizar la homosexualidad y
penalizan completamente una el aborto
luego de casi 100 años
uno entonces son más grandes que hemos
tenido a nivel de país que está pasando
en toda centroamérica todos los países
de centroamérica
viendo en esta serie
un movimiento feminista todo eso se
inició en parte en eeuu y ahora estamos
viendo ese retroceso enorme analiza si
es para mí para mí es importante que se
reconozca que esto es una cuestión
mundial ahora es mundial que si bien es
cierto que el salvador tiene una de las
políticas más fuertes para las mujeres
que abortan o sea son 10 y más de 17
mujeres pero estás nicaragua no hay
ninguna todavía pero sabemos que las
mujeres no están llegando a los
hospitales porque tiene un miedo
espantoso si eso significa que las
cifras de niñas madres de las niñas o de
la mortalidad materna incrementan
tenemos 317 mujeres presas por haber
abortado y la condena es de 15 años
todas son mujeres pobres todas son
mujeres menores de 25 años que ya son
madres que ya tienen uno o dos o tres
hijos
ese es el problema porque el estado es
inconsciente del gasto social que
significa el cuidado de los hijos de
otros de otros recursos entre otras
cosas porque además vivimos
latinoamérica vive esta situación de que
más o menos siempre va a haber otra
mujer que asume el trabajo de cuidado no
importa que la madre esté presa siempre
siempre va hasta la abuela la tía la
vecina la si entonces nos movemos con
una dinámica bastante absurda y la parte
de conocimiento grande con respecto a lo
que pretende la ley la ley de
despenalización del aborto implica que
aquel que quiera por cualquier motivo
puede hacerlo es libre de hacerlo o no
eso no implica porque hay leyes sociales
a todas las mujeres a todas las que la
ley no tienen que ver con eso tiene que
ver con
digamos uno en su interior decide si
loción o educación pasa por un tema
claro lo que nosotros pedimos como
movimiento feminista es mayor de
educación para decidir acceso a
anticonceptivos para no abortar y aborto
seguro para no morir solo y bueno y hay
que decir que hablamos de las partes
negativas caso contrario de lo que
ocurre aquí en canadá a ese nivel a
nivel de mujeres a nivel de las
comunidades el fbi no me acuerdo
perfectamente del 2017 en la gran marcha
del orgullo gay en toronto que es una de
las más grandes del mundo fue encabezada
por el primer ministro canadiense haga
la primera vez que un primer ministro
participaba activamente en una marcha y
a partir de ese momento lo están
haciendo en general los políticos se los
ve en montreal en vancouver en toronto
al frente de esas marchas que yo creo
que ahí cuando hablamos de educación esa
foto tiene un gran gran abandono en la
sociedad de hecho el primer ministro de
ontario doctor
que es progresista conservador y
entonces ahí yo creo que eso es parte de
lo cuando uno dice educación también es
eso es pues acá tenemos la suerte yo lo
digo de tener un primer ministro
progresista
y hablando de canadá que están haciendo
en canadá bueno tuvimos la suerte de
recibir el apoyo de equitas que es una
fundación que trabaja en derechos
humanos aquí en canadá para ser parte de
un programa de entrenamiento en derechos
humanos a nivel internacional es un
espacio realmente maravilloso somos 96
personas de 48 países que estamos
participando en el evento entonces hemos
podido conocer mucho más cuáles son
todos los instrumentos
ejercicio pleno de derechos humanos cómo
se puede hacer un informes anuales cómo
acceder al sistema de naciones unidas
para hacer denuncias o reclamos como
países en materia de derechos humanos
pero lo más rico definitivamente desde
el conocer contextos y realidades
completamente distintos no por ejemplo
yo pienso en mi caso uno viene cargado
de prejuicios de qué pasa con los países
musulmanes qué pasa con los países del
áfrica porque no actúan porque no
reacciona porque son tan machistas
porque cuando uno se conoce un poco más
del contexto y cómo funciona
su sistema social su sistema político
realmente no comprende que existen
muchas más estrategias pero también
ellos han aprendido mucho de nosotros
absolutamente el movimiento feminista y
el gti en américa latina tiene
estrategias muy ricas y creo que años de
luchas también la larga larga data
entonces más fiel que es lo que te
llevas desde estas tres semanas de
trabajo bien intenso como difícil
principalmente estaba pensando que antes
de venir acá
hicimos una evaluación de casi dos horas
y yo está describiendo que también me
tocó de construir un montón los
prejuicios que tenía para como otros
países centroamericanos y del
sudamericano y otros lugares creo que lo
que me llevo es que a pesar de que
vivimos en contextos culturales y
políticos y económicos super diferentes
trabajamos con una misma estrategia y
seguimos poniendo la cara a los
gobiernos a los estados a las demás
personas a la misma comunidad para
defender derechos para seguir trabajando
en seguirnos construyendo a nosotras
mismas y seguir construyendo espacios
seguros para otras poblaciones sin
dejarnos a nosotras atrás porque también
nosotros importamos más cierto
ahorita comentabas y decías que el
movimiento el eje ético
en tu país que sale solo
[Risas]
y después desaparece o sea pero qué es
lo que hace porque tiene que desaparecer
es la persecución es el miedo que sucede
y es quien realmente no hay una
articulación o un movimiento yo desde
que recuerdo hace 10 años tal vez que me
metí de lleno en todo esto yo nunca he
sentido realmente un movimiento no sé si
tiene que ver con persecución porque
hasta hace un año estábamos
relativamente bien en nicaragua que lo
que tiene que ver con la cuestión de el
protagonismo que se da durante estas
fechas porque nicaragua hay que
reconocer que los 28 de junio serán
fechas muy significativas donde no
solamente salíamos a la calle por salir
a la calle sino que salíamos a
reivindicar derechos y exigir al estado
que se nos reconociera en el código de
la familia porque no estamos reconocidos
para sí igual que en ecuador ya otros
lugares donde se establece que la
familia es una mamá y un papá y los
hijos del gato
mi perro y el gato ni la abuela ni nada
más que solamente el papá la mamá y los
hijos creo que lo que tiene que haber es
como un fortalecimiento a las pocas
organizaciones que están en el país él
gmt lo que sí tengo que reconocer de
movimiento en nicaragua es el movimiento
feminista que está muy muy involucrada
con el movimiento de la diversidad
sexual que es un movimiento que se
mantiene todo el tiempo y creo que el
movimiento de la diversidad sexual tiene
mucho que aprender de este movimiento
feminista bueno muy bien les agradecemos
entonces la presencia se quedan
igualmente con nosotros unos minutos más
en esta emisión pero queremos
agradecerle formalmente antes de pasar a
otro tema la presencia a maría cordero
pérez y a maciel moreno les invitamos a
volver cuando quieran
y les agradecemos muchísimo esperamos
que la situación entonces en sus
respectivos países mejore y poderlos
tener aquí nuevamente en el futuro con
mesa de la coordinación efectivamente
siempre conociendo qué es lo que van
haciendo en cada uno de los organismos
de los que ustedes participan porque
sabemos que no están involucrados
solamente con un organismo tienen una
larga trayectoria y es variadas así que
sería interesante en un futuro también
tener la posibilidad la ocasión de
conocer el resto de sus ocupaciones
muchísimas gracias muchísimas gracias a
ustedes al contrario y como hacemos en
cada emisión y cada semana a nuestro
público a quienes nos siguen tanto a
través del sitio web como de las
emisiones por el facebook live youtube
les pedimos que nos envíen vídeos o
fotos de los lugares en los que viven
para conocer mejor para conocer un poco
más para conocer algunos detalles
en torno del cual cada uno de ustedes se
recibe si no tienen vídeos puede enviar
vídeos también como ustedes quieran
pablo verá dichos vídeos las dos las dos
posibilidades son viables después de una
diversidad de idiomas en esta ocasión es
daniel camporini nuestro viejo y
conocido amigo daniel camporini quien
nos ha hecho llegar algunas fotos de un
barrio tradicional borleña lección de
buenos aires no se ha hecho llegar fotos
del barrio de palermo
daniele del mundo pero es un barrio muy
tradicional de buenos aires- el más
grande de la ciudad de buenos aires y el
más populoso tal es así que se lo ha
subdividido popularmente en distintos
barrios para poder darle cabida en el
imaginario colectivo entonces está el
barrio de palermo viejo etcétera
etcétera
estas fotos no se envió no tengo yo más
o menos más información sobre las fotos
pero si no me equivoco en ese olfato
porteño que todavía perdura lo que te
queda es el pasaje santa rosa
en lo cierto ha confirmado que está
ubicado precisamente en el barrio de
palermo viejo muy cerquita de la
plazoleta julio cortázar ex
[Música]
cuando vivía en san luis que es así o
sea me acuerdo el nombre de la calle
pero ahora no tengo idea es una plaza
muy pintoresca rodeada de pubs y bares
hay un sistema de fotos que servía un
mojito excelente y daniel nos ha hecho
llegar entonces algunas fotos algunas de
ellas las vivimos otras están en nuestro
sitio en internet y agradecemos entonces
la inquietud le agradecemos que siempre
esté presente con nosotros de una u otra
manera y reiteramos entonces que sigan
el ejemplo de l'àngel y que nos hagan
llegar fotos y vídeos si tienen daniel
morín y nos dice correcto louis
[Aplausos]
y horas unas semanas
fuera con algún momento las cientos
compañías los colegas los viejos colegas
de otros medios me cargaban y mencionan
que en algún momento yo había sido el
fundador de buenos aires o taxista en la
ciudad
pero no se agotan así las imágenes no se
pueden agotar todo el favor que como
ustedes saben hoy precisamente hoy
precisamente se lleva a cabo la
inauguración oficial del nuevo puente
samuel es amplia aquí en montreal y se
puede liar y la p-18 une la ciudad de
montreal con la ribera sur y ya la
semana pasada se pudo transitar una de
las manos precisamente la mano que va
desde la ribera sur hacia la ciudad de
montreal porque es importante este
puente este puente es importante primero
por la inversión que requirió que son
los 6000 millones de dólares y segundo
porque es uno de los puentes más
transitados de américa del norte tanto
por vehículos particulares como por
transporte de cargas este nuevo puente
de samuel de champions viene a
reemplazar el viejo puente se amplia que
está al costado no aparece en la foto
pero que es la estructura metálica que
es una estructura en parte metálica y en
parte cemento pero que precisamente por
la enorme cantidad de cemento se
determinó muy rápidamente y duró mucho
menos lo que tenía que durar tiene
apenas 50 años inaugurado y sin embargo
cuando uno lo mira parece que tuviera ya
200 años de existencia ya tengo casi 50
casas entonces el deterioro se note en
más de un sentido no solamente en el
puente sino también en otros normalmente
pero en todo caso este puente va a estar
inaugurado oficialmente hoy la mano que
va desde montreal hacia la ribera sur va
a ser transitable a partir del lunes y
es toda una novedad y esas fotos tan
preciosas que en las tomo y esas fotos
de empresas
vamos a dar el crédito a la colaboradora
del tubo dinámico a mi señora que anduvo
paseando con su teléfono móvil
saco fotos está condenado por la ley
pero por si esto fuera poco las fotos no
terminan allí tampoco hay transporte
también queremos mostrarles qué son las
de el barrio de verdad en el centro sur
de la ciudad de montreal que hacen muy
poquitas horas inauguró una planta qué
maravilla no sólo inauguró una playa
además de la playa este año también la
isla festival internacional de jazz
varió esta semana se desplaza se
descentraliza de montreal y tiene un
ordinario
perdón dice se descentraliza estamos
hablando de un metro a otro metro es
decir no estamos lejos no no no no
estamos lejos pero gracias al elecciones
salió del escenario de montreal para
otra pequeña un barrio más que verdad
que así se aguanta está haciendo que
verdad se conviertan a poco a poco en
una atracción más y ahí tiene esa bonita
playa hermosa que para estos días de
calor no viene nada mal es el río san
lorenzo
ese es el río se agrava efectivamente
hay un predio muy bien ubicado muy bien
deformado hay sistemas de seguridad
pueden ir los niños tranquilamente hay
espacios suficientes para todo el que
quiera llegar y a quienes no tengan la
posibilidad porque no cuentan con
vacaciones por el momento porque no
tienen recursos porque no pueden viajar
en este momento o lo que fuere pueden a
darse un chapuzón allí hay también
actividades naúticas muy cerca con gente
que anda en motos acuáticas en acá
en botes etcétera así que poquito a poco
ese viejo barrio de verdad que supe
habitar en algún momento hacía ya
algunos años va ganando vuelo tenía
bares tenía bares también entonces va
dado a dar cierta información de lo que
viene pasando aquí vamos a dar cabida
algunos los mensajes que nos están
llegar bueno luego del correcto louis de
tener el campo línea y tenemos a otro
top fun miriam alarcón que nos envía
saludos daniel nos explica que las
próximas fotos van a venir con detalles
muy bien y mire nada con dice los
estamos viendo desde tú en tucumán
argentina así que un abrazo grande que
mande fotos de tucumán
más cerros
muchos cerros
ingenios
[Música]
están paralizados porque están hechos
justamente para que la gente lo tome con
una atracción turística no te van a
poner adentro de los tanque mando la
caña pues pero es que aunque estás lejos
igual la sientes de tucumán yo sólo
conozco la canción lunita tucumana y
bueno ahora algo de la luz habíamos
prometido ser precisos porque como
dijimos al comienzo de la misión tenemos
muchísimo para hoy y lo que ya no
tenemos muchísimo es tiempo
tenemos demasiado material o somos muy
locuaces los invitados son súper
interesantes todas las semanas también
así que tal vez deberíamos extender
nuestro espacio de difusión vamos a
tomar en cuenta
[Música]
[Risas]
a pasar entonces a los temas que la
sección ha estado trabajando a lo largo
de la semana y como es tradicional
también en cada emisión les rescata
vamos les proponemos uno de esos temas
por cada uno de nosotros pero recuerden
que hay mucho más en nuestro sitio de
internet en este caso vamos a darle la
palabra en todo caso a lyon ahora para
que nos cuentes cuál es el tema que
rescata de todo lo que hace el trabajado
es gato y es por él por el lindo final
que tiene porque estamos hablando
siempre muchos de los problemas que
encuentran los trabajadores temporales
extranjeros cuando llegan acá problemas
de adaptación pero también problemas de
explotación entonces esta es una
historia linda estamos viendo ahí a noé
arteaga él es de origen guatemalteco era
una activista social también acá edes
trabajaba en un organismo en montreal en
defensa justamente de los trabajadores
temporales pues se estuvo muchísimo
tiempo ocho años viviendo
real hasta que se trasladó hace dos años
más o menos a halifax en la provincia de
nueva escocia se fue a trabajar a
aprender el inglés a hacer otras cosas y
pues ahí lo vemos este 19 de junio
recibió la ciudadanía canadiense
entonces en este sentido creo que es
valorar valió la pena hizo un largo
camino no es arte haga lo conocemos
desde hace mucho tiempo lo entrevistamos
muchas veces entonces me decidí un poco
a contar esta historia que me parece que
tiene un final el lindo feliz
porque es un gran día para nosotros los
inmigrantes exhibimos la ciudadanía
acuérdense y un poco le pregunté que
cambiaba eso en la vida de él y me dijo
a mí nivel personal no pero en otro
sentido si voy a poder votar si vienen
las elecciones en canadá también se
puede presentar a ocupar un cargo
político y va a seguir trabajando dijo
con los trabajadores temporales pueden
felicitaciones entonces a noé arteaga
otro ciudadano canadiense más
proveniente del exterior
pablo señor cuál es el tema que rescata
si esta semana es un tema de
sobrepasamiento del ser humano no es un
quebequense que se llama me perdí que a
los 20 años tuvo un accidente de
automóvil y quedó parapléjico entonces
él
se dedicó desde entonces
para practicar todos los deportes que
podía con su hándicap y uno de los
deportes que aprendió es ahí lo vemos en
una bicicleta de manos como no se puede
utilizar sus piernas tiene que
propulsarse con las manos entonces se
dio un desafío para recaudar fondos
justamente para niños autistas y para
personas con hándicap físico y mental se
dio el desafío de atravesar todo canadá
siete mil doscientos kilómetros desde la
ciudad de vancouver hasta la ciudad de
halifax cuando se conversó con él estaba
aquí en quebec ya cinco mil 900
kilómetros más tarde entonces me pareció
una historia bonita yo creo que los que
estén más interesados pues pueden
consultar la isla a ver y escuchar en
nuestro sitio internet es perfecto antes
de darle la palabra a leonardo no por
falta de cortesía sino porque está en el
guión y para nuevo problematizar le el
trabajo a nuestros técnicos les presento
el tema que yo estuve trabajando esta
semana que tiene que ver con el cambio
climático
de nuevo brunswick el cambio climático
afecta a todo el país ya todo el mundo
lo sabemos pero en el caso específico
del nuevo grupo y que ha habido un
reciente estudio que ha detectado por un
lado que la temperatura promedio sube en
esa provincia más rápidamente que en el
resto del país lo cual es alarmante está
muy cerca del promedio del resto de
canadá pero duplica el incremento de la
temperatura promedio en el mundo que los
hago está problematizando la vida de los
habitantes locales porque sabemos que en
nuevo brunswick el calor no reina no no
son valores agobiantes los que se llegan
a vivir allí como en otros lugares como
los que están haciendo todas aquí en
montreal por ejemplo en europa aparece
en francés siguen y esto trae aparejado
problemas como por ejemplo un incremento
de las precipitaciones más calor
lang y por supuesto inconvenientes en la
vida cotidiana que pueden llegar a
desencadenar problemas mentales
enfermedades mentales y es algo que está
ya preocupando a las autoridades de esas
de esa provincia entonces hay un informe
elaborado haciendo
o tres días por mi parte que está ya
también en el sitio en internet y por
último leonardo gimeno antes rápidamente
12 19 26 de julio y 2 de agosto estamos
de vacaciones como el programa lo vamos
a ir avisando con tiempo pero no quería
olvidarme de decirlo para que la gente
sepa que el 12 el 19 el 27 julio y el 2
de agosto no va a haber programación es
imponer realidades se desee se estila en
la casa en radio canadá a tomar
vacaciones las los programas son muy
exitosos entonces bueno lo mío tiene que
ver con nada porque se afianza y amplía
su oferta para la salud el primer
producto para diabetes ya en algunas
tiendas de apple store
esto es one drop es un pequeño artefacto
para sacar para hacer la medición de la
glucemia exacto del azúcar en sangre es
para los diabéticos y qué diferencia hay
entre el aparatito que te lo pinchas en
tu casa y los pases que éste tiene un
montón de datos va juntando datos de
funcionar con un algoritmo dentro del
teléfono y va recopilando datos con el
cáncer y otras cosas no pero yo puedo
poner por ejemplo yo tengo tengo cinco
números que están asociados al mío para
que se lo tenga una hipoglucemia o una
hiperglucemia le avisé a mis familiares
para que te merece eso
entonces en el sitio y también
disponibles los invitamos a que lo vayan
a ver ustedes están escuchando la
cortina final eso quiere decir que
nuestro programa por hoy se terminó
prácticamente les agradecemos como
siempre habrá estado una vez más con
nosotros les agradecemos también
nuevamente a maría cordero pérez y a
maciel moreno haber participado de la
emisión y nos despedimos entonces hasta
el 9 de agosto
[Música]